[Music]  there's a primal urge in all of us to  explore  [Music]  some say private citizens have no  business of space exploration i  emphatically disagree we have a historic  opportunity the first mission to mars  nasa's joining helios and the soviets a  three-way race to mars we're not going  to come in second place again to anyone  we're talking about discovering life on  another planet it'll change our concept  of who we are where we're going  [Music]  the massive dust storm has obscured both  landing sites years even decades of  planning comes down  to this moment  we're landing blind  brings for impact  being first is what it's all about  this is the resource that can support  large-scale human colonization  want to tell us where the water is  the survival of my crew depends on  [Music]  when united behind a common goal there  is nothing we cannot achieve  it's only the beginning  [Music]  [Music]  you